when you showed it back in the mid 80s
you know you said you screamed it for a
little bit
how was it received then
the fashion was probably still very
similar music was still relevant to when
you show it now
well i think now in some ways if there's
a nostalgia factor if you were there it
brings you back to that time period and
if you're
a young person who wasn't around then
you can see how it was and maybe maybe
be entertained
i think we were lucky to have
entertaining material on camera
and
you know it just was a lucky break and
that we got this stuff and it all kind
of came together in a very short time
period and some of the material was
really uh entertaining
but um
you know it just was we were fortunate
and and it's been uh uh you know that
people have favorites i mean the kind
the characters in it you know even if
they're on screen for a very brief
period of time you know people like
certain characters
um some characters really stand out and
also
you know lines stand out and i think
what happens
a lot what i've always found is most of
the metal community hasn't really it
wasn't really the fans of heavy metal
that that embraced it it was fans of
kind of alternative rock and
and uh
just the different you know
you know you weren't finding it
circulating among
the heavy metal crowd necessarily they
came to it eventually but i don't think
it was something they sought out and
also was they didn't have that much
exposure i mean again it was just it was
really kind of word of mouth and
and people that might have a copy they
were having parties and they'd show it
to you but really that whole tape
trading culture you know the kind of
underground tape trading culture is what
it really uh benefited from greatly
well so when you screened it in the 80s
what was the reception versus i mean you
know heavy metal sort of they always say
it died an ugly death once grunge came
and these new bands you know nirvana
allison chains kind of
just squashed all those people and now
there's been a resurgence it seems like
because it is nostalgic but what was
that initial reaction back in the 80s
when people still had the
well again those people weren't the ones
that were seeing it necessarily it was
people that were more interested in
alternative music or what have you i
don't even like labels but i have to
just for the sake you know the punk rock
crowd or the
the original rock crowd or what have you
not necessarily the heavy metal or the
hair metal crowd um we're we're seeing
it i mean i mean i shouldn't say that
because i know people did see it there i
i just i i don't know i can't really i'm
just sensing that
nobody was embracing it as much as these
people that were interested in um
you know alternative
college radio the college radio crowd
right that was what was
seemed to embrace it more than the heavy
metal crowd or the hair metal crowd but
i think everybody who saw it that was
from that kind of came up at that time
that you know there's just something
evocative about it like i say you you
didn't have to be at that concert to
know
those type of people or
that kind of
passion for for music
you